champ du coq meuglement des vaches bruit
des tracteurs ou encore bâtiments
imposants autant de réalités sonorees
visuelle ou olfactive qui ne sont pas
toujours du goût des néoruraux ces
urbains ayant quitté l'effervescence des
métropoles pour la tranquillité des
villages mais ces dernières années le
phénomène a pris de l'ampleur 490
procédures sont en cours contre des
agriculteurs à travers la France pour
troubles anormaux de voisinage une épée
de Damocles pour les producteurs et un
frein à leur développement économique
selon les syndicats agricole nos
agriculteurs travaillent tous les jours
pour nourrir les Français s'il faut
sortir le tracteur le dimanche ou la
nuit pour semer le blé après des
semaines de pluie nous le faisons car la
nature n'attend pas plusieurs affaires
ont déjà bouleversé le monde agricole
comme celle de Vincent verchoueur
éleveur laitier dans l'Oise il a été
condamné en octobre 2022 à verser plus
de 100000 € de dommage et intérêt pour
avoir construit ses nouvelles étables
trop près de ses voisins et ce en dépit
de permis de construire conforme face à
cela le ministre de la Justice et c du
pont Moretti a promis de réagir une
proposition de loi visant à réduire
drastiquement les procès abusifs et à
respecter l'entériorité des activités
agricoles sera examiné le 4 décembre
prochain à l'Assemblée nationale les
nouveaux habitants des campagnes ne
peuvent pas pour un oui ou pour un nom
se plaindre en justice de leur voisin
agriculteur s'il était installé avant
eux et qu'il a obtenu toutes les
autorisations administratives pour
exercer son métier aujourd'hui seule la
loi dite du coq Maurice protège le
patrimoine sensoriel des campagnes don
partie les activités agricoles problème
pour être applicable il faut un
inventaire précis des sons et des odeurs
considéré comme caractéristique d'une
région or jusqu'à présent seul les Haut-
defance et l'Auvergne ronalp ont amorcé
la
[Musique]
démarche